Country like Spain,
who do not have the slightest doubt.
and if it weren't for the fact that we are in 1 european
we would already be Argentina.
We often believe we are superior
and we laugh and make fun of each other
of what happens
in the countries on the other side of the Chaco.
We say these guys,
we will never do that.
Well,
Spain is already the 4th country
of the entire European Union with the highest poverty rate.
We are only surpassed by Romania,
Bulgaria and Greece.
This is our reality.
The reality is
that the Spanish nation has been doing for many years now
that does not get
increase their wealth,
but the other way around,
we are becoming more and more impoverished.
Do not believe
that what is happening in Argentina cannot be given here.
Some will say,
well,
monetary policy Thank God,
does not depend on the Spanish ruler.
The money supply at the end of the day
which is the fundamental thing
when we talk about supply issues
and many others.
What is
what Argentina has done all these years?
You cannot do it here
because they will concentrate in Europe.
This would be for another debate,
but hey,
they cannot do it,
but imagine that I could,
because just as Argentina has created
1 clientelistic system
in which more than half of the population
depends directly on the state,
in Spain we are on the same path.
Do the numbers,
if it is very simple,
make the numbers
and they get 16 million working people
in the private sector,
on the other hand,
have 11 million pensioners,
3 million unemployed
and 3 million employees,
17 million people
that they collect each month through the state